foreign
[Music]
comments on his appearance in the new
Harry Potter series Zack Snyder sets up
his own Star Wars universe and The
Chronicles of Narnia is being adapted
into new movies plus there's news about
really naughty food a purple dinosaur
for adults and the fate of John Wick 5.
here's this week's keynote check news
there's chaos surrounding John Wick as
recently as May Lionsgate boss Joe Drake
stated that work was already in progress
on part 5 but now director Chad
stachelski has spoken out and casts
doubts on whether John Wick 5 will in
fact be released in an interview of
Empire The Mastermind behind the series
talked about the idea of continuing the
story of Keanu Reeves's role he thinks
John Wick 4 brought the series full
circle and is a very good ending for the
series many fans think so too which is
why Joe Drake's announcement naturally
caused quite a stir now the question
arises how that coincides on the one
hand the development of John Wick 5 is
confirmed on the other hand the director
of the series apparently knows nothing
about it and is actually of the opinion
that there is no need for a fifth part
but that doesn't mean another sequel is
out of the question stahlski adds in the
interview that he's excited to give it a
try despite everything just to see if
they can pull it off however he does not
have a concrete idea for it yet
regardless of whether John Wick 5 ever
becomes a reality fan fans will get a
follow-up either way on September 22nd
2023 the three-part sequel series the
Continental from the world of John Wick
will be released on peacock followed
next year by the spin-off film ballerina
starring Anna dearmus including an
appearance by Kiana Reeves
watch out things are getting naughty
Seth Rogen's sausage party is becoming a
series in 2016 the animated movie was
the first of its kind to receive the
notorious R rating in the United States
for adults only as the comedy Legend has
now revealed the series is set to take
things to the next level sausage party
Utopia will comprise of Eight Episodes
and take viewers back to the kinky
Supermarket it was obviously an
important concern for Seth Rogen to warn
more critics and viewers in advance that
some of the scenes will be really
intense Rogan literally calls the series
incredibly shocking and talked in an
interview about one particular scene
that will be the subject of much
discussion after the release for this
scene alone Amazon Prime's PR team is
said to have had a screening of their
own just so they know what they're in
for already in the previous film there
had been a scene that later caused a
sensation as it involved a humorously
interpretated sexual assault this did
not go down well with every journalist
or audience member however this did not
affect the success of sausage party to
this state it is the most successful
R-rated animated film ever so that's a
good reason for those responsible to
pick up where they stopped as Rogan and
his colleague Evan Goldberg announced
they put just as much heart into the
series but even more jokes and culinary
intercourse than before the release date
for sausage party futopia is planned
next year and we're curious to see how
far Rogan and Goldberg will actually go
in the end
Harry Potter is returning in the form of
a series but what about the former main
actors who became world famous with the
eight part film series Daniel Radcliffe
has now broken the silence and announced
how things actually stand regarding his
potential return since the release of
the video game Hogwarts Legacy earlier
this year the Wizarding World seems to
have entered a new phase the success of
the game probably also played some part
in the fact that the new Harry Potter
series was announced a few weeks later
in an interview with comicbook.com
Radcliffe commented for the first time
on the rumors that he would be part of
the series and would once again take on
the role of the eponymous wizard as far
as he knows those responsible are trying
to make a fresh start with the series he
wished those responsible the best of
luck and looks forward to the torch
being passed without his direct
involvement this statement is certainly
unfortunate for many fans but it is
hardly surprising after all both
Radcliffe and his colleagues Emma Watson
and Rupert Grint have made great efforts
in recent years not to be reduced to
Harry Potter anymore this in turn will
make it all the more difficult for the
people in charge to get the numerous
potterheads excited about the new series
without the well-known actors after all
it's not just about another story like
an adaptation of the play The Cursed
child but a retelling of the well-known
original books which is undoubtedly a
difficult task to undertake HBO Max's
current schedule precedes the first
season starting in 2025 at the earliest
probably more likely in 2026 then an
impressive seven seasons are to be
released at relatively short intervals
in 10 years in other words one season
for each book incidentally Creator JK
Rowling is involved as a producer which
has so far LED Die Hard fans to believe
that the series will be a success either
way there's some time left before it all
starts and potterheads around the world
are eagerly awaiting the news of the
actors involved
Zack Snyder meets Star Wars initially
his next movie Rebel moon was planned to
be part of the world famous franchise
now Snyder has revealed in recent
interviews why nothing came of it but
new images clearly show that Snyder is
now simply working on his own Star Wars
Vision Snyder proposed the project to
lucasfilm shortly after the Disney
acquisition the Justice League director
had exact ideas he insisted on not using
characters from the existing Star Wars
Canon and wanted to create a movie that
was not rated PG these conditions
ultimately led lucasfilm to reject the
project Disney obviously placed too much
emphasis on the recognizability of Star
Wars and the young audience Rebel moon
is roughly based on the film's seventh
Samurai by Akira Kurosawa this is no
coincidence since George Lucas was also
inspired by the Japanese star director
for his own film series The Story of
Rebel moon is about a young woman who is
looking for capable Warriors to defend
her home against an invasion the story
is to become part of a larger unit
Universe the background of which has
already been written down in a 450 page
film Bible this is to serve as the
foundation for further movies and series
it contains for examples guidelines for
the rough pot and ideas for further
projects but also visual concepts and
character backgrounds as part of
Snyder's interview with Empire new
images of the movie were also published
they show for example a woman wielding
two blades of red light which is again
strongly reminiscent of Star Wars also
shown as a mysterious robot voiced by
Anthony Hopkins and a well-toned
character that could easily be one of
the recruited Warriors Rebel moon hits
Netflix on December 22nd a special
aspect here is the fact that two cut
versions will be released at the same
time one for Miners and one aimed at
adults despite the Star Wars similarity
Snyder has now created a standalone film
that will surely appeal to both Star
Wars fans and sci-fi lovers we are
looking forward to more news
from Barbie to The Chronicles of Narnia
the legendary fantasy story is to be
filmed again this time for Netflix the
director is reddickerwig who is
currently causing a sensation with her
Barbie adaptation starring Margot Robbie
and Ryan Gosling as reported by the New
Yorker at least two new Narnia movies
are to be produced Netflix had already
acquired the rights to the book series
by C.S Lewis in 2018. since then both
new movies and a series have been under
consideration Narnia was last seen in
three feature films The Lion The Witch
in the wardrobe was released in 2005
followed by Prince Caspian in 2008 and
finally The Voyage of the Dawn Treader
in 2010 Greta Gerwig is to direct as
well as write the screenplay for the new
film adaptations of The Chronicles of
Narnia the renowned project would be the
next milestone in her young directing
career after spending many years as an
actress she had her breakthrough as a
director in 2017 with the five-time
oscar-nominated ladybird the literary
film adaptation little woman soon
followed in 2019 and at present Barbie
seems to be a huge hit will the success
carry you over to the Netflix adaptation
of The Chronicles of Narnia we'll keep
our eyes and ears open for you to find
out more about the project
the childhood of the 90s and 2000s
becomes the horror of today the purple
dinosaur Barney is coming to the big
screen but unlike what you would expect
instead of appealing to the young
audience of the cult series Barney and
Friends the movie is aimed at grown-ups
Daniel kaluya is known to many as an
actor from get out and nope in an
interview with a New Yorker he spoke
with his unconventional idea for the new
movie in his role as producer he
literally said he wanted to address the
fears of the Millennials the generation
that grew up with Barney's children's
Series so the focus is on the issue of
today's 30 year olds and their
disenchantment with many things in life
the new Barney movie is supposed to be
downright surreal and inspired by The
Works of Charlie Kaufman and Spike Jones
anyone who has seen kaufmans and Jones's
Being John Malkovich should have an idea
of where things are headed so we can
expect some artistic aspirations that
shouldn't have much in common with
childhood star Barney however an R
rating is not being actively targeted
it's apparently the content rather than
the brutality that is a 10 did for an
adult audience in his interview however
kaluya only scratched the surface as far
as his ideas for the film are concerned
current wise he did not want to comment
on the project yet but at least the
production seems to be moving forward
and we can possibly count on more new
soon by the way if you prefer to see the
childish side of Barney you can look
forward to the release of a new animated
series produced by Mattel next year
well that's the news for this week what
do you think can Zack Snyder compete
with Star Wars do we need any new Narnia
films and will the Harry Potter series
be a success let us know in the comments
if you want to continue watching more
content take a look at our latest
preview of the new Captain America Brave
New World movie thanks for watching and
see you next week for more kenocheck
news
[Music]
thank you